die Werbewirtschaft wird sich die Haare
raufen Sarah Wagenknecht nicht vor
Jahren engagiert zu haben als Talent als
Marke für erfolgreiche Botschaften so
ist Sara wagennecht jetzt Namenspatronin
und Ikone für eine Parteigründung
geworden ihre alte Partei hat sie damit
in Existenznöte gebracht die
Neuformation soll für Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit stehen hat man allerdings
auch schon anderswo gehört
bündniswagenknecht was wird aus der
Linken jetzt in der
[Musik]
phönixrunde
phönixrunde herzlich Willkommen bei uns
meine Gäste zugeschaltet aus harztor am
Harz ist Ines Schwertner sie sind
Mitbegründerin eines sozialistischen
Magazins namens
jacobin sie sind jetzt in die Politik
gewechselt und kandidieren für die Liste
der linken zur Wahl zum Europäischen
Parlament im Juni des nächsten Jahres
Hanna Betke ist politikredakteurin bei
der Welt Sebastian Puschner leitet das
Ressort Politik und ist
stellvertretender Chefredakteur des
Wochen der Wochenzeitung Freitag und
Julia ruschenbach ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin an der Freien
Universität Berlin und forschen unter
anderem sie forschen unter anderem zu
Parteien und politischer Kommunikation
Herr Puschner nach einer langen
Hängepartie hat SAR wagen jetzt die
Gründung einer eigenen Partei verkündet
wie ist dieser sch Schitt zu werden ist
das eine Klärung der Verhältnisse oder
könnte das ein Todesstoß für die Partei
sein der sie bisher angehört hat wenn es
ein Todesstoß wird für die Linke äh dann
war es ein mit von dieser
herbeigesehnter denn auf beiden Seiten
ist ja die Unvereinbarkeit in den
vergangenen Jahren immer deutlicher
geworden viele wollten dass sie geht
jetzt ist sie gegangen und insofern
schafft das klare Verhältnisse ja
SAR wagenkncht war ja das bekannteste
Gesicht der Partei DIE LINKE kann diese
doch chronisch schwächelnde Partei im
Moment chronisch schwächelnd ohne sie
überleben nein ich denke dass die
Linkspartei Geschichte sein wird aber
nicht nur übrigens durch den Weggang
jetzt von Sarah Wagenknecht sie haben
auch selber schon sehr viel dazu
beigetragen dass sie sich im politischen
System dieses Landes nicht halten können
Frau schtner sie sind jetzt ausgerechnet
in einer Zeit in der schon viele der
Abgesang auf die Linken anstimmen vom
Journalismus in die Parteipolitik GEW
wechselt also genauer gesagt kandidieren
sie jetzt bei der Wahl zum Europäischen
Parlament warum haben Sie das gemacht
ist das für Sie kein
Risiko na ja ich finde gerade jetzt ist
es unsere gesellschaftspolitische
Aufgabe um diese Partei zu kämpfen weil
es einfach kein Land ohne linke geben
darfchenbach die Parteienlandschaft ist
in Bewegung was das jetzt alles bedeutet
dieses Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht da
kommen wir noch drauf zu sprechen äh
aber was wirde es für die das
Parteiensystem der Bundesrepublik
bedeuten wenn die Partei DIE LINKE vom
Tableau verschwinden würde na ja
zunächst mal eine linke Kraft weniger
haben wir gerade schon gehört und
natürlich damit ähm aber gleichzeitig je
nachdem ob andere dafür einziehen würden
vielleicht eine Beruhigung ja wir haben
ja gesehen das Parteiensystem hat sich
immer weiter ausdifferenziert in in den
letzten Jahren insofern ist die
spannende Frage nicht nur verschwindet
eine Partei sondern käme eine andere
dazu wir könnten ja auch das
Gedankenspiel anstellen die Linke bleibt
und ein bündniswagenknecht kommt noch on
top dazu das würde die Fragmentierung
verstärken ist eine Fragmentierung
generell schlecht für eine Demokratie
die ja vom Pluralismus lebt nein also
grundsätzlich nicht sie erschwert
natürlich in den meisten fen
Mehrheitsbildung und
koalitionsbildungsprozesse das kann dazu
führen wir schauen ja sich sicherlich
auch noch auf die ostdeutschen
Bundesländer im Laufe der Diskussion
dass man tatsächlich vor großen
Herausforderungen und Problemen steht
aber grundsätzlich ist natürlich ein
Parteiensystem immer auch ein Abbild
dessen was sich in der Gesellschaft
findet und wenn da eben milieös
Meinungen Positionen ausdifferenzieren
dann trifft das im Parteiensystem auf
Wiederhall im Zusammenhang mit der jetzt
geplanten Neugründung machtte das Wort
von der
repräsentationslücke die Runde das es
für eine ganze Reihe von Wählerinnen und
Wählern eigentlich keine Partei im
Angebot gibt die Sie wählen könnten und
oft aus äh Verzweiflung oder anderen
Gründen dann die AFD wählen äh auf der
Website des Vereins Herr Puschner das
heißt dieser Verein der die Gründung
vorbereitet
Bewegung Sarah Wagenknecht für Vernunft
und Gerechtigkeit da liest man vier
große Themen die konsensfähig sein
sollen für die Partei und für die
Wählerin und Wähler ähm wirtschaftliche
Vernunft soziale Gerechtigkeit Frieden
und Freiheit ich kenne niemanden der das
schlecht findet
was verbirgt sich da wirklich dahinter
also erstmal ist überraschend an dieser
Vorstellung der doch sage ich mal ganz
klare Fokus auf wirtschaftspolitische
frageestellen vor allem auch
Sozialpolitik viele haben jawartet es
wird viel mehr noch um Migration
restriktive Migrationspolitik gehen das
taucht auch in ein gewissen Art und
Weise auf aber ist doch erstmal jetzt
sekundär war auch bei der Vorstellung
gestern nicht so sehr im Fokus gestanden
und in allererster Linie geht es
sozusagen darum Ungerechtigkeit
Ungleichheit zu konstatieren etwas
dagegen zu machen und vor allem aber das
aufzugreifen was man doch in vielen
Ecken des Landes in der einen oder
anderen Form hört nämlich Kritik an der
Wirtschaftspolitik der regierenden
Ampelkoalition und dagegen gegen diesen
Irrsinn also Zitat jetzt Wagenknecht
eine Stimme der Vernunft die auch gerade
die industrielle Wertschöpfung in
Deutschland sichert und ich glaube das
ist durchaus was was reüieren kann und
worauf jetzt erstmal am Anfang der
Schwerpunkt liegt jetzt ist es ja so
dass die Quadratur des Kreises und ein
Hufeisen geometrisch eigentlich was
völlig unterschiedliches ist meint aber
offensichtlich im Zusammenhang mit
dieser zukünftigen Partei das gleiche
dass da ganz unterschiedliche Positionen
vertreten werden die dieser Kombination
bislang im deutschen parteiens System
gar nicht vertreten waren wen spricht
denn diese programmatische Verknüpfung
die Sarah Wagenknecht da auf der
Pressekonferenz skizziert hat an ja also
Wagenknecht hat ja völlig richtig
erkannt dass es eine präsentationslücke
gibt da würde ich ihr zustimmen in
dieser Analyse es gibt ein
Vermittlungsproblem
der derzeitigen ampelregierung gegenüber
den Bürgern da gibt und da geht sarip
die Wutbürger an das ist ihr Adressat
und da gibt es auch durchaus
Überschneidungen zu anderen politischen
Rändern auf der rechten Seite obwohl ich
da trotzdem große Unterschiede auch sehe
aber um diesen Reflex zu bedienen da
verfolgt sie eine ganz ähnliche
Strategie und ich würde übrigens sagen
sagen ja eine Fragmentierung an sich das
muss also um noch mal auf Frau
Reuschenbach Bezug zu nehmen das muss
jetzt an sich eine Demokratie nicht
Schwächen aber wir haben ja jetzt hier
nicht nur das Problem einer politischen
Fragmentierung sondern einer politischen
Radikalisierung und das ist schädlich
für die bürgerliche Mitte und das ist
die eigentliche Beunruhigung die ich in
Verbindung mit Sarah wagenknechtsplänen
zur Neugründung dieser Partei sehe ich
weiß nicht ob sozusagen der Begriff der
Radikalisierung zumindest das in dem
Programm das dann jetzt vorgestellt
wurde wirklich trifft denn eigentlich
lese ich da ganz viel alte
Sozialdemokratie raus
Umverteilung mit Steuerpolitik die
heimische Wirtschaft stärken
Leistungsgesellschaft leistung muss sich
wieder lohnen und vor allem natürlich
Friedenspolitik Außenpolitik direkte
Bezugnahme auf willip Brand und Egon Bar
das ist schon fast eine Spur sage ich
mal überraschend sehr vernünftig was da
drin steht oder was zumindest viele als
vernünftigchuldigung da muss ich kurz
wiedersprechen weil SAR Wagenknecht in
den Vordergrund stellt dass die
Sanktionspolitik gegen Russland
aufgehoben werden soll um die Wirtschaft
wieder anzukurbeln das also damit
verlässt sie den Konsens auf dem die
derzeitige Regierung und der vernünftige
Teil der Gesellschaft würde ich jetzt
mal sagen wenn die FDP hört Leistung mus
ich wieder lohnen sollte sie sich nicht
zu früh freuen denn in Wirklichkeit ste
FDP wird nicht so blauäugig sein
irgendetwas gutes wir wollen ja nur die
Begriffe auseinanderhalten Frau
Schwertner die zurückgelassenen nämlich
die Partei DIE LINKE für die sie jetzt
kandidieren haben durch Gregor giesi
ihre Position oder die Position von
Entschuldigung von Sarah Wagenknecht so
beschrieben sie will mischen
Sozialpolitik wie die Linke
Wirtschaftspolitik wie Ludwig Erhard und
Flüchtlingspolitik für die
AFD ein Erfolgsrezept oder ist das zu
holschnitzartig immerhin was ja Gregor
Gesi der das gesagt
hat ja also ich glaube hat es ganz gut
zusammengefasst aber das zeigt auch wie
widersprüchlich diese Positionen sind
also ich gehe eigentlich davon aus dass
das vielleicht im ersten Moment
attraktiv klingt aber dass es auch in
sich implodieren wird also sie hat auch
gar keine Vorstellung davon wie das
umzusetzen sein soll und ich glaube das
ist das was man schon auch gemerkt hat
bei der Pressekonferenz bei Nachfragen
dann auch von Journalisten
dass da die Widersprüche ganz ganz
schnell rauskommen wir kennen ja auch
noch gar nicht dann das vollständige
Programm und die Debatten und die
Kandidierenden und ich glaube das wird
noch alles
viel viel
weiter offen in alle Richtungen ist es
jetzt schon das heißt man kann sich da
überhaupt nicht drauf verlassen was da
programmatisch eigentlich genau kommt
von ihr FR rchenbach ist das
gemischtwenladen das kommt drauf an wie
es da können ja Mobs Fidel zugehen je
nachdem wie viele coshoooter noch in die
Partei finden dass man sich da relativ
schnell schon zerlegt ist es eine echte
Gefahr für diese neue Partei
grundsätzlich ja also wenn Parteien sich
neu gründen dann leiden Sie selten daran
dass sie so nicht gleich Mitglieder
erfen würden weil das neue zumal mit
einer solch populären und in vielen
Teilen der Bevölkerung ja auch beliebten
Persönlichkeit wie Sarah wagenknechtes
ist das zieht natürlich an man hat aber
auch schon bei der Vorstellung gestern
raushören können dass die Partei oder
besser gesagt noch ist es ja gar keine
Partei der Verein da vorsichtig sein
will man will genau prüfen wer wer
Mitglied werden kann und soll man will
langsam wachsen weil natürlich klar ist
dass da jetzt auch ich glaub Frau warn
hat den Begriff Glücksritter unter
anderem verwend versuchen in so einer
Partei unterzukommen
ich würde aber gerne Stichwort gemischt
waren Laden noch mal beim inhaltlichen
bleiben denn ich teile Frau Betke nicht
die Diagnose zu sagen nur weil die
Bundesregierung politisch kommunikativ
ein Vermittlungsproblem hat also die
Menschen mit dem was sie tut
offensichtlich nicht erreicht oder nicht
hinreichend adressieren kann hat man
deshalb nicht gleich zwingend ein
repräsentationsdefizit also man hat vor
allen erstmal ein Kommunikationsdefizit
das würde ich gerne sozusagen dazwischen
schieben und der zweite Punkt ist dass
ähm bei der Diagnose was bietet dieses
Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht jetzt ähm für
mich vor allen Dingen die Botschaft
bleibt Populismus bleibt Populismus also
wenn man sich diese Vorstellung gestern
angeschaut hat dieses Programms dann
wurden vielen da Sätze wie die
EU-Kommission in Brüssel also
populistisch übersetzt die da oben die
Politik mache gegen die eigene
Bevölkerung das sind so ganz klassische
Sätze dann wurde formuliert man müsse
mehr Zugverbindung schaffen zwischen den
europäischen Staaten man brauche ein
besseres erasmusprogramm das war also
noch sehr weit weg von der Frage wie
denn wirtschaftspolitisch tatsächlich
z.B Deutschlands Verbleib in dieser
Europäischen Union und die
Zusammenarbeit dort aussehen soll also
da würde ich ein großes Fragezeichen
auch dran machen wie programmatisch
substantiell das was wir da jetzt lesen
konnten diese ersten drei Seiten
momentan tatsächlich erstmal sind aber
das muss man vielleicht inhaltlich auch
noch mal anreich anreichern her Puschner
da ist jetzt in Bezug auf die
Europäische Union so gesagt worden glaub
ich wörtlich das muss Europa muss eine
souveräne Demokrat es müssen souveräne
Demokratien der Nationalstaaten sein das
ist original oder Originalton Vikor
Orban das heißt und gleichzeitig wird
Brüssel sozusagen als als Wasserkopf als
bürgerfernes Monstrum hingestellt
Lobbyisten von Großkonzern würden da nur
den Ton angeben das das eine was mir
aufgefallen ist bei den Äußerungen von
sarwagen nicht das andere ist sie
spricht von einem verengten
meinungskorridor in der öffentlichen
Diskussion in Deutschland mit Verlaub
das ist klassisches AFD framing was hat
sie vor mit solchen Äußerungen das heißt
sie hat natürlich bestimmte Wählerinnen
und Wähler im Auge das wird beim Mix der
Themen und dem wie sie sie ausspricht
und gewichtet deutlich werden weil wen
sie damit im Sinn hat das ist ja das ja
ganz klar das sind nicht nur
afd-wählerinnen und afdwähler sondern
das sind vor allem Menschen die jetzt
nicht unbedingt in Innenstadtbezirken
deutsche Großstädte wohnen sondern äh
ganz oft auch in der Provinz äh dort wo
sie auch Lesungen macht und verengter
meinungskorridor ich meine ich sag immer
ganz gern es wird heute oft vorgebracht
man könnne nicht mehr frei sagen was man
denke faktisch kann jeder das tun und
tut es auch reichlich aber Moment wo er
sagt dass man nicht mehr frei denken
kann sagt er ja seine freie Meinung
darüber genau aber natürlich wir hatten
ja gerade schon kurz angeschnitten das
Thema ukrainekrieg Waffenlieferung für
den ukrainekrieg ohne jetzt diese Frage
sozusagen inhaltlich zu diskutieren aber
das ist doch einen bemerkenswerten
Anteil von Menschen gibt in Deutschland
die diese Waffenlieferung und die
Haltung der Bundesregierung sozusagen
kritisch sehen und dass die auß in der
AFD im Moment überhaupt keine
Repräsentation finden das kann man
glaube ich nicht bestreiten und dass der
Ton in dieser Debatte natürlich von
beiden Seiten durchaus scharf ist und
sage ich mal solche Vokabeln wie Putin
Freund oder sowas sehr schnell über die
Lippen gehen das spielt sie natürlich an
und damit wird sie doch den ein oder die
andere überzeugen denke ich mal ich
finde die Kritik die sie jetzt gerade
geübt haben an dem Begriff des
meinungskorridors ausschließlich der AFD
zuzuschreiben das ist ein Teil des
Problems und ich glaube da müssen wir
wirklich aufpassen dass wir uns nicht
die Themen tabuisieren lassen nur weil
die AFD sie aufgreift und es gibt es
gibt immer noch mal ein Unterschied ob
man das Recht auf Meinungsfreiheit auf
freie Meinungsäußerung hat od Frage ja
das stellt das ist richtig das stellt
die AFD in Frage das ist aber nicht
etwas was Wagenknecht so ausgesprochen
hat also da muss man jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen und schon auch genauer
hingucken finde ich ein bisschen
differenzieren sie hat durchaus wie ich
finde einige Punkte treffend beschrieben
und dazu gehört auch ein bestimmtes
Meinungsklima das meint sie ja damit
also dass bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr
ausgesprochen werden können ohne dass
eine totale Polarisierung in der Debatte
eine große Aufregung entsteht dazu
gehören diese identitätspolitischen
Reflexe die auf linker Seite auch sehr
stark bedient werden dass sie davon sehr
genervt ist hat sie auch in ihren
Buchveröffentlichungen immer wieder
gesagt und sie finde ich schon dass der
Begriff der Lifestyle linken oder der
Selbstgerechtigkeit einer bestimmten
Schicht von Linken da hat sie ja da
trifft sie ein Punkt und da trifft sie
Nerv bei bestimmten Bürgern das ist ja
jetzt nicht so dass sie sich das alles
ausdenken würden es gibt ein sehr
eingeengtes Klima in der Debatte im
Moment das würde ich auch sagen ohne
dass des deswegen die rechte beschnitten
würdenner sind sie denn die eine in
einer Partei der Style linken die
Identitätspolitik macht also eine
Politik die so im urbanen Milieu en wog
ist
und hat die das ist ja der Vorwurf an
die Linke
hat den Kontakt eigentlich zu ihren
eigentlichen stammwählerinnen und
Wählern
verloren also ich glaube der größte Witz
jetzt auch an dieser Geschichte auch an
der Pressekonferenz war dass sie sich
damit einem Millionär hinsetzt und auch
sagt dass sie auch gerne große dass sie
spenden animm von Unternehmen was die
Linke übrigens äh nie tun würde also wie
nahe sie zu den Arbeiterinnen und
Arbeitern ist das sei noch mal
dahingestellt ich habe auch nicht
gesehen wann sie das letzte Mal bei
einem Arbeitskampf war oder sonst
irgendwie ein Streik unterstützt hätte
also ich glaube äh das was sie der
Linken ganz gern vorwirft und wo sie
vielleicht auch insgesamt wenn sie jetzt
meint sie denkt redet über die ganze
gesellschaftliche linke oder das was sie
davon hält ähm sie war da zuletzt glaube
ich gar nicht so viel anwesend an den
Orten wo es entscheidend gewesen wäre
nämlich wirklich bei den Menschen die in
Armut leben und die Linke macht das
jeden Tag ich sitze ja hier gerade eben
in Thüringen und war bei basisgenossen
die Infostände machen zu steigenden
Mieten und ich habe nicht gesehen wie
das
jetzt die
ehemaligen Genossinnen und Genossen
zuletzt getan haben also ich finde da
spielt auch eine hohe doppelmoralene
Rolle und auch
Sarah Wagenknecht bei aller Geduld jetzt
auch mit ihr die viele hatten hat ihre
Bücher veröffentlicht es kann Touren
kann alles sagen was sie will also ich
glaube sie muss mit diesem opfergestus
jetzt auch irgendwann aufhören also sie
ist wirklich eine der wenigen die
überall alles sagen kann was sie möchte
ja den Punkt würde ich gerne nur noch
mal verstärken ich teile Frau bke was
sie sagen dass man sozusagen aufpassen
muss wessen sozusagen Definitionen man
sich vorschnellt zu eigen macht und zu
sagen das ist AFD framing ich glaube
gerade wir haben hier in der Runde schon
mal über die Frage diskutiert kann man
AFD und Linke in einen Topf werfen und
waren uns am Ende eigentlich bitte bitte
differenzieren aber ich glaube schon
dass eben Frau Wagenknecht ja gemessen
werden muss an dem was sie selbst
sozusagen anbietet und das sind eben 750
000 € Nebeneinkünfte durch Ihr Buch das
ist eine Demonstration die sie hat
organisieren können in einem Land mit
Meinungsfreiheit vor dem Brandenburger
Tor mit 13 000 Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmern wo sie alles sagen konnte
zur Ukraine zu Waffenlieferung zur
Forderung nach Frieden und Diplomatie
also da glaube ich würde ich doch auch
sagen D und das ist letztlich am Ende
die Aufgabe von Wählerinnen und Wählern
die jetzt diese Partei im Angebot
wiederfinden muss man natürlich prüfen
ob man ob das glaubwürdig erscheint das
was da jetzt angeboten wird und zu sagen
wir haben da eine also eine Verengung
des meinungskorridors
und da eine Polarisierung da muss man
natürlich auch da sagen dass auch Frau
Wagenknecht dazu beiträgt ich erinnere
an Aussagen z.B über die Grünen als
gefährlichste Partei im im Deutschen
Bundestag wo man wenn man ihr glaubt
dass sie gerade die Abgrenzung zur AFD
auch möchte natürlich auch fragen kann
welchen welchen Sinn welche oder mit wie
viel ohne Not muss man dann solche
Aussagen tätigenchner ist
die eigent Lifestyle linke SAR
Wagenknecht das ging jetzt hier so ein
bisschen zwischen den Zeilen
zumindestens so zu verstehen also sie
hat meiner meiner Erinnerung nach
gestern nicht gesagt dass sie
Unternehmens und konzernspenden gerne
annimmt sondern ausdrücklich dass sie
das nicht tun will dass jetzt da ein
Millionär der für die Besteuerung von
Spitzeneinkommen und großen Vermögen
wirbt bei ihr mitmacht ist glaube ich
einer der eine der durchaus kleinen
Überraschungen die hat er mitgegründet
genau aber ich glaube dass es
letztendlich darauf ankommen wird ja
genau wie wie gesagt wie sie das dosiert
also sie braucht diese Polemiken diese
Einspritzer um
Leute auch zu zu zu
zu mobilisieren aber auf der anderen
Seite will sie eigentlich inhaltlich auf
was anderes hinaus ihr großes
Steckenpferd ist die Wirtschaft ist die
Sozialpolitik darüber würde sie glaube
ich wenn man sie wenn sie sich frei
entscheiden könnte gern die ganze Zeit
reden aber natürlich wird sie immer
wieder auch versucht sein genau diese
Spitzen in Sachen cancel C und so weiter
zu setzen
und sage ich mal das
auszutarieren das hat sie ja bis jetzt
das sieht man an ihrer anhaltenden
Popularität immer ganz gut
hingekriegt die Frage ist wie das jetzt
in den kommenden Monaten sein wird mit
einem extrem erhöhten aufmerksamkeits
mit einer extrem erhöten Aufmerksamkeit
gerade auch von Medien ein weiterer
Punkt ist ja Migration Beschränkung der
Zuwanderung da hat allerdings jetzt war
möglicherweise Olaf Scholz schneller als
sarawagenknecht wir müssen endlich im
großen stitil abschieben sagt er und
gleichzeitig eben die Zuwanderung
beschränken hat sie da möglicherweise
ihren Moment verpasst hat sie noch vor
der Gründung ihrer Partei das
Alleinstellungsmerkmal
Migrationspolitik ja mit anderen
Aussagen arbeitet als die AFD also wenn
man das jetzt rein aus strategischen
Gesichtspunkten aus ihrer Perspektive
sich anschaut dann kann man jetzt sagen
hat sie vielleicht ein bisschen Pech
gehabt ich habe also mir ist das
aufgefallen in der Bundespressekonferenz
dass das gar nicht im Vordergrund stand
das Thema und auch erst sowieso
angesprochen wurde auf
Nachfrage aber auch da würde ich sie hat
sich ja vorher schon immer wieder dazu
geäußert dass zu viel Zuwanderung das
Land überfordere auch da finde ich hat
sie einen wichtigen und richtigen Punkt
und den wird sie auch weiter besetzen
das ist ja ist ja Teil dieser Strategie
oder das ist das wenn Sie von einer
repräsentationslücke spricht die
übrigens also insofern schon besteht als
bestimmte Bürger sich eben nicht mehr
repräsentiert fühlen das das war ja der
Punkt daran
was jetzt die Wirtschaftspolitik
betrifft da finde ich da würde ich her
Puschner wiedersprechen ähm da müsste
man dann noch mal schauen wie sich das
weiterentwickelt ich finde da gibt es
überhaupt keine Anleihen bei der
Sozialdemokratie sondern bei der
Linkspartei also das ist im Prinzip
setzt sich das da fort bis hin zum
Vokabular dass sie hier bedient sie hat
einen ziemlich antikapitalistischen
Jargon da drin und das das Großkonzerne
dass da der der Reibach abgeschöpft
werden muss so sinngemäß wird das da
gesagt und das erinnert doch in vielen
Punkten schon an ihre alte Partei und da
da müsste man mal schauen in wie weit
dieses Bündnis in der Lage sein wird
sich davon abzugrenzen oder ob es
überhaupt noch nötig ist weil die
Linkspartei sich bis dahin vielleicht
von alleine erledigt aber Frau
Schwertner werden sie denn s sich mit
der Partei von Sarah Wagenknecht äh
darum kloppen wer der beste
Antikapitalist die beste
antikapitalistin
ist also erstmal es ist noch keine
Partei es jetzt schon so viel Medienhype
jetzt für eine Gründung eines Vereins um
das noch mal festzustellen also wir
reden hier eigentlich darüber äh dass es
eine Pressekonferenz gab und vielleicht
jetzt spenden und Interessierte das
gleiche gab es übrigens bei Aufstehen
auch schon es hat zu nichts geführt also
ich finde auch das muss man mal ein
bisschen den Boden den Ball flach halten
und einfach mal dabei bleiben und wir
wissen überhaupt noch nicht was da
programmatisch kommt wer dazu kommt das
ist das eine das heißt wenn sie sich
ieren sollte wovon ich gar nicht ausgehe
aber wenn Sie das tun sollte ist sie
wahrscheinlich eher eine Gefahr für die
anderen Parteien und nicht für die
Linkspartei das sieht man jetzt an
ersten Umfragen auch wenn man den
vielleicht wenn man die mit Vorsicht zu
genießen sind aber ich glaube da zittern
jetzt eher andere Parteien eben gerade
aufgrund dieser wie sie gesagt haben
migrationskritischen Aussagen wegen
dieses Kulturkampfs das machen die
anderen das machen schon AFD CDU und
jetzt auch SPD
und ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt gar
keinen Antikapitalismus drin also wer
ihre Bücher gelesen hat der weiß dass
ihr Ludwig erh weit näher ist als Karl
Marx also da mache ich mir gar keine
Sorgen dass da für uns noch irgendwie
noch genug Kapitalismuskritik übrig ist
da ma ich mir keine
Gedanken ja und also ergänzend dazu
Sarah Wagenknecht ist vielleicht ein
zentrales aber eben auch nur ein Problem
der Linken gewesen in den letzten Jahren
wir haben ja in der Anfangsrunde schon
kurz so den Blick geweitet ich glaube
die Frage nach der der Zukunftsfähigkeit
der linken und nach der Frage wie
antikapitalistisch oder wie man
überhaupt programmatisch sich in Zukunft
aufstellt die ist ja eine die die Partei
schon viel länger beschäftigt wenn man
auf mitgliederschwunde schaut auf die
Landesverbände auf die Fliehkräfte die
diese Partei in den bei den letzten
Wahlen äh erlebt hat bei der Europawahl
sie haben ja eben die die anstehende
angesprochen 2019 hat die Partei in
allen Generationen in alle sozialen
Gruppen überall hin verloren also und
das ist natürlich nicht alleine das
Verdienst von Sarah Wagenknecht sondern
sie ist auch einfach nur ein Teil einer
einer gesamtmisere und die spannende
Frage und ähm da komme ich noch mal
zurück auf auf Frau Betke in der
eingangsrunde ist ja macht die Partei
was draus also kann man jetzt Überleben
als Befreiungsschlag kann man sich
programmatisch erneuern oder kann man es
nicht und ich wäre da nicht ganz so
pessimistisch zumal ja momentan die
Bundesregierung und die Zwänge dieen die
linkeren Parteien in der Bundesregierung
unterliegen eigentlich Raum öffnet für
eine linke oppositionsstimme die man aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen paar haben wir
schon genannt gar nicht nutzen konnte
jetzt seit Beginn dieser Legislatur die
aber eigentlich ein Möglichkeitsraum
wäre zumal angesichts der Themen von
Wohnungsnot Inflation und vieles mehr
die ja traditionell durchaus linke
Themen wären so man sie denn mit guten
programmatischen Antworten besetzen
könnte die nicht nur heißen umverteilen
umverteilen aber das ist ja jetzt nicht
einfach nur eine weitere linke Partei im
bürgerlichen Spektrum sondern
Wagenknecht verlässt das und das ist
wird besonders augenfällig in der
Außenpolitik und darüber wird zu
sprechen sein wenn wenn sie sagt man
müsse jetzt eben auf die Diplomatie
setzen und dürfe keine Waffen mehr
liefern und als sei das alles ganz
einfach als sei das jetzt möglich sofort
Verhandlungen mit Putin zu führen und
die Weltordnung neu zu sortieren da wird
es dann auch ein Problem haben also ich
glaube schon dass Wagenknecht viele
Chancen haben könnte also dass das diese
Partei erfolgreich wird nur wenn es dazu
kommen sollte dann wird künftig die
Regierungsbildung noch komplexer werden
denn da sie diesen Konsens verlässt
können eigentlich die etabliert
bürgerlichen Parteien nicht mit ihr
zusammen kaliieren genauso wenig wie mit
der AFD was das dann für das
Regierungssystem bedeutet das wird also
mindestens eine Herausforderung und
könnte auch zu einer Destabilisierung
führen z.B nächstes Jahr in Thüringen
ist ja möglicherweise das dann wirklich
ganz Komplex jetzt sind hier mehrere
Gedanken schon geäußert worden zu SAR
Wagenknecht und auch zur Rolle der
Linken in der Zukunft es könnte ja sein
dass SAR
Wagenknecht doch noch über die eigenen
äh Füße stolpert denn sie hat mal gesagt
im Vorfeld der Parteigründung klassische
Parteiarbeit wä ihr zu viel sie hat die
Struktur Aufbau von 16 Landesverbänden
Personal und so weiter genannt das werde
sie nicht leisten können die Frage hat
sie denn dieses Durchhaltevermögen denn
es gibt ja auch für Sarah magenknecht
auch für die neue neue mögliche Partei
sowas wie die Mühen der Ebenen nach
diesem Hype am Anfang
das ist eine Anschub äh ein Anschub für
die Partei aber dann muss sie zeigen was
sie kann ich glaube das ist tatsächlich
die größte Herausforderung sie hat das
dass ihr das nicht liegt eigentlich ja
schon seit dem Ende als
Fraktionsvorsitzende relativ offen immer
gesagt sie hat es jetzt am Anfang doch
überraschend gut geschafft da Leute ums
sich zu schauen die ihr genau das
Abnehmen der Staat lief auch aus Sicht
der Initiatorin und Initiatorinnen
ziemlich glatt also von muss man doch
sagen dass also hat mich auch persönlich
doch ein bisschen überrascht gerade auch
was die Diskretion an geht es wurde ja
ich sag mal keine Partei war so bekannt
dafür für gezielt gestreute Indiskretion
wie die linke und das wurde auch genau
diesem Flügel immer wieder vorgehalten
aber tatsächlich sind auch diejenigen
die neun anderen aus der Fraktion die
sie um sich geschartt hat auch am
Wahlabend in Bayern und Hessen wo ich
sag mal einen Klaus Ernst ja gern mal
vielleicht auch schon was rausgepoltert
hätte
was er nicht hätte rauspoltern sollen
ruhig geblieben und also bis jetzt läuft
das aber wenn es im Januar dann losgeht
gerade auch diese enge Kontrolle des
Mitglieder zu Flusses auszuüben und die
Glücksritter
krieristen Leute deren politische
Positionen man nicht teilt hat Christian
lei glaube ich gestern gesagt die
sozusagen auszusieben und und da genau
drauf zu gucken wer kommt da und wen
wollen wir wen wollen wir nicht und wie
können wir den Kreis eng halten das das
nimmt ganz schön viel Zeit in Anspruch
das ist eine ganz schön große
Herausforderung und da wird's
tatsächlich noch mal spannend aber
radikale Kräfte profitieren von
Krisenzeiten deshalb und ich wurde nach
wie vor Wagenknecht im Bereich der
radikalen Kräfte einordnen insofern
glaube ich stehen die Chancen noch nie
so gut wie jetzt also spielt ja einfach
die Zeit zu und dass sie das kann diese
populistischen Reflexe zu bedienen das
zeigte sich auch daran dass sie dann
behauptete die jetzige Regierung sei die
schlechteste in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik was ich wirklich eine
Anmaßung find also ich bin jetzt weit
aus nicht Sprecherin dieser Regierung
aber das ist nun also das ist so
überzogen und eigentlich auch so
plakativ dass das weiß sie auch selber
eigentlich unter ihrem Niveau ist oder
oder wenn wenn sie sagt wenn sich jetzt
nichts ändert dann werden wir in 10
Jahren dieses Land nicht wiedererkennen
was will sie denn damit suggerieren was
will sie damit sagen sie schürt damit
Ängste Ängste vor Veränderung obwohl sie
sehr genau weiß dass wir inmitten einer
tiefen Transformation stehen und dass
Veränderung nun mal anstehen und dass
den Bürgern vermittelt werden muss auf
eine gute Weise dieser Zustand der
Republik wird im nächsten Jahr
sicherlich nicht sehr viel anders sein
als heute heute im nächsten Jahr Wahl
zum Europäischen Parlament Frau
Schwertner sie treten da an danach
gibt's aber auch noch entscheidende Wahl
nämlich im Herbst da sind sie entweder
schon im Europäischen Parlament oder
auch nicht kann es oder befürchten sie
denn dass möglicherweise das Auftreten
von Sarah Wagenknecht z.B bei der
Landtagswahl in Thüringen dazu führen
wird dass der bislang einzige
Ministerpräsident ihrer Partei in
Thüringen Bodo ramelo dadurch um sein
Amt
kommt also ich se hier gerade auch in
Thüringen und habe heute wirklich mit
vielen Genossinnen und Genossen
gesprochen an der Basis das ist genau
das was ja Sarah WN nicht eben nicht
getan hat wahrscheinlich in den letzten
Jahren nämlich weil es wirklich viele
Leute gibt die sich hier jeden Tag
hinstellen bei Wind und Wetter und mit
den Leuten sprechen da draußen und ich
will noch mal dazu sagen dass in allen
ostdeutschen Bundesländern kein einziger
Bundestags niemand mit Bundestagsmandat
niemand mit Landtagsmandat mit in diese
neue Partei geht ich sehe nicht wie in
diesen Landesverbänden wo es dann
Landtagswahlen geben wird ein eine
andere Partei aufgebaut wird aber sei
das mal dahinestellt genau das was sie
sagen es droht nämlich eine ganz andere
Katastrophe nämlich genau der der
Rechtsruck und genau das das doch das
Problem dass man einerseits die Kritik
an der ampelregierung hat die hat man
den rechten überlassen gleichzeitig ich
meine hier jetzt auch im Studio wurde
gesagt
dass das heizungsgesetz oder die
Klimapolitik nur ein
Kommunikationsproblem ist nein es ist
natürlich eine wahnsinnig unsoziale
Politik und auch diese Sparpolitik die
die Bundesregierung jetzt fährt ebenn
mit genau den Weg für den Aufstieg der
AFD und der ist aufhaltbar aber der ist
eben nicht dadurch aufhaltbar dass man
einfach schöne Reden hält oder Bücher
verkauft sondern dass man diese
kernearbeit vor Ort macht und das hat in
den letzten Jahren immer die Linke
gemacht und deswegen finde ich sind wir
da eher der Garant für die Demokratie
als irgendjemand der sich dahinsetzt und
dann einfach mal so ein paar Spitzen hat
gegen die Grünen das reicht halt nicht
das müssen allings auch die Wählerinnen
und Wähler z.B in Thüringen dann auch
begreifen und so sehen Frau ruschenbach
wir haben ja jetzt schon in Thüringen
den Zustand dass linke plus AFD eine
Koalition der Mitte verhindern kommt
jetzt noch Sarah Wagenknecht dazu egal
jetzt in welcher Konstellation das ist
wahrscheinlich keine Kaffeesatzleserei
dann gibt's die erst recht nicht also es
muss aber irgendwann eine Regierung
geben in Thüringen nach der Wahl in
welche oder an welche Parteien ist denn
eine wir gehen davon aus das kommt jetzt
zu einer Parteigründung wäre denn diese
Partei Gründung von Sarah Wagenknecht
anschlussfähig also erstmal ein eine
kleine Randnotiz die kommt auch gar
nicht von mir sondern vom amtierenden
Ministerpräsidenten in Thüringen von
Bodo ramelo
der Hinweis darauf dass die Regierung
die momentan im Amt ist ja so lange im
Amt bleibt bis eine neue gebildet ist
das glaube ich darf man nicht
unterschätzen mit Blick auf die Wahl im
nächsten Jahr dass dieser Punkt wichtig
werden könnte
angesichts komplexer schwieriger
regierungsbildungsprozesse
äh und die Anschlussfähigkeit ähm
ja also die fußt ja darauf dass wir in
diesem Jahr im Frühjahr und auch jetzt
im Herbst noch mal so erste Daten und
Umfragen gesehen haben wo könnten denn
wählerpenziale für ein eine solche
Partei von Sarah Wagenknecht liegen die
sind mit extrem viel Unsicherheit
behaftet aus politikwissenschaftlicher
Sicht wird man da leicht nervös weil das
sind ja alles im Grunde Zukunfts ist
Zukunftsmusik das sind Luftschlösser wir
nichts ist belastbar von all dem und ich
erinnere das tauchte auch schon auf in
den Medien diese Woche daran dass es mal
von ein paar Jahren um Frage gab ob sich
wie viele der deutschen sich vorstellen
könnten eine Horst Schlemmer Partei zu
wählen die hatte ähnlich hohe
wählerpotenziale wie das Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht also sozusagen nur um den
Rahmen zu setzen für das was ich jetzt
sage
sie kann offensichtlich anschlussfähig
sein
in das wählermilieö der AFD insoweit es
um die diejenigen geht die mehrheitlich
der AFD ihre Stimme geben würden aus
Protest und Unzufriedenheit und dabei
und zunehmend ähm was die Zahlen zeigen
billigend in Kauf nehmen oder am Ende
gar nicht so schlimm finden dass die
Partei in weiten Teilen rechtsextrem ist
ähm sie würde auch eine gewisse
anschussfähigkeit sicherlich erzeugen in
ein traditionelles sozialdemokratisches
Milieu das der Hinweis viel eben schon
ähm und sie hat und das glaube ich ist
wichtig wenn wir über 2024 sprechen
einfach ein enormes ostdeutsches
popularitätspotenzial also während die
Partei ihre bisherige Partei DIE LINKE
ja mal mit weita aus mehr Mitgliedern im
Osten ausgestattet war als im Westen
jetzt liegen die Zahlen ungefähr gleich
auf also hat man einen rapiden
mitgliederschund gemacht hat ihre
Popularität nichts eingebüst im
Gegenteil das heißt die würde sicherlich
und das ist eine spannende Frage
mit Blick auf die Mühen der Ebenen also
die Dauerhaftigkeit des Erfolges erst
einmal davon profitieren dass sie nicht
nur bekannt ist das haben wir auch schon
z.B bei Franziska giffer gesehen hat
nicht geholfen sondern vor allen Dingen
beliebt also die Leute mögen sie und das
könnte nächstes Jahr tatsächlich ein ein
Faktor sein der nicht nur bei den
wählermilies inhaltlich AFD SPD habe ich
jetzt genannt ähm Potenziale wegt
sondern vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus
weil sie einfach als Figur ähm
interessant ist und für viele vielleicht
eine hoffnungsfigur kleine Einschränkung
es bleibt am Ende natürlich auch so dass
sie nicht überall antreten kann sie kann
nicht zur Europawahl antreten und in 16
Bundesländern antreten also irgendwann
wird sich auch rauskristallisieren
müssen wo Sie persönlich ihren
Schwerpunkt sieht und ich würde vermuten
der könnte vor allem in Ostdeutschland
das heißt die amtsträgerinnen und Träger
und Funktionäre von Ampel und Union
können erstmal beruhigt schlafen aber
wird nicht so viel anbrennen dass ich
die in Ostdeutschland AFD und Sarah
Wagenknecht sozusagen bekämpfen und
hätte dann erstmal keine unmittelbaren
Folgen für die anderen Parteien ich
glaube die Kritik s wagenknechts an der
Ampel wird sehr laut bleiben sie wird
auch weiterhin auf die auf die Grünen
sicherlich
abzielen und sie hat ja gestern auch
gesagt es wird definitiv keine
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD gehen geben
aber sie rate dazu nicht die ganze Zeit
über die AFD zu diskutieren rauf und
runter sondern über vernünftige Politik
das ist ja sozusagen ihr ihr neues
Schlagwort
und das wird sie selbst denke ich mal
auf jeden Fall tun es wird ja immer
vorgehalten sie soll sich deutlicher
absgrenzen sie soll sozusagen klar
bekennen und so weiter ich mE das hat
sie gestern mit einem Satz getan aber
sie wird das nicht jetzt in extenso
weitertun weil das natürlich ihre
Chancen mindert genau bei einem milieö
zu zu Erfolg zu haben dass in Teilen
vielleicht die AFD schon gewählt hat
oder das damit lilieb eugelt sie zu
wählen und dass die ganze Zeit sozusagen
mitkriegt dass darüber geredet wird wie
man das denn nur machen könne die AFD zu
wählen also da hat sie glaube ich einen
strategischen Vorteil und vielleicht um
die die die Ostdeutschland Popularität
noch mal zu untermalen ich war vor
einiger Zeit bei einer Lesung von ihr in
Sachsen Anhalt äh südlich von Magdeburg
und alle redeten von
ähm von von schulnotenabschaffung
schulnotenabschaffung also aus dem
Publikum kam die Frage neben mir die
Frage schulnotenabschaffung sie hat es
dann sehr gekonnt aufgegriffen hat
gesagt ja also ich merke das ja heute
wenn mir ostdeutsche E-Mails schreiben
die hab beherrschen eine weitaus bessere
Rechtsschreibung immer noch als als als
als westdeutsche und das kommt halt auch
davon dass man in der Schule ich will
kein preußisches Schulsystem aber
Büffeln und Pauken muss auch manchmal
was und großer Applaus also nur mal so
um um zu untermalen wie sie sozusagen da
ich glaube sie hat ihren Dirk Oschmann
gelesen und dessen Buch und wie sie das
sozusagen ausspielt und ja Schulnoten
abschaffen das war ein Kernbestandteil
des äh Positionspapiers der Linkspartei
vor kurzem ä im September ähm also ich
glaube sie hat da sehr gute Chance kein
interessiert ne da war das eben nicht
hat es keinen Resonanzraum erfahren ganz
anders als wenn sie dann da ist und sie
sich für solche Themen ST die Leute
haben es tatsächlich von sich aus
thematisiert mir war das gar nicht mehr
gegenwärtig dass die Linkspartei das vor
kurzem gefordert hatte aber es kam dann
eben raus und das hat die Leute
eschoffiert und so
ich will jetzt keine Diskussion über
Schulen anfangen aber es ist zeigt doch
ganz gut wie sie das macht und für wie
lang und ob das länger als für sag ich
mal die nächsten ein zwe J Wahljahre
reichen wird das ist natürlich erst noch
mal eine große Frage so einer Partei
Neugründung bei Neuorientierung bei
Bewegung im Parteiensystem ist es nicht
weit zu den Legendenbildungen das haben
wir jetzt auch schon gemerkt welchen
Anteil hat in SAR werkenknecht an dem
beklagenswerden Zustand der Partei DIE
LINKE sie hat ja so das Gefühl ich bin
da nicht durchgedrungen die sind von
ihren Wurzeln von ihrer eigentlichen
Orientierung abgekommen und jetzt muss
ich da raus ja es ist ja innerhalb der
Linkspartei sehr verbreitet die Schulter
sozusagen bei Wagenknecht vorrangig zu
sehen ich finde dass das ein sehr
bequemer Ansatz ist also wie gesagt ich
bin jetzt keine Anhängerin von Sarah
Wagenknecht aber in der Linkspartei ist
einfach sehr viel schief gelaufen ich
finde es sowieso sehr schwierig äh was
da da fiel der Satz vorhin überhaupt von
Sozialismus zu sprechen und zu glauben
man Stärke damit die Demokratie heute
finde ich an sich schon im Ansatz
hochproblematisch und ich glaube auch
nicht dass man damit heutzutage noch
Wähler gewinnen kann die Linkspartei hat
in Ostdeutschland es eine Weile
geschafft dort eine sehr wichtige ein
sehr wichtiges Sammelbecken zu sein auch
aufgrund der DDR Vergangenheit die auch
in der Partei wie ich finde bis heute
nicht richtig aufgearbeitet worden ist
insofern würde ich jetzt gar nicht den
Fehler vorrangig bei Wagenknecht sehen
sie hat dazu beigetragen dass es
irgendwie lebhafte Debatten und
Konflikte und alles mögliche gab aber
sie ist nicht der Auslöser dafür dass
die Linkspartei heute so schlecht
daasteht Frau schedner wenn jetzt der
störnfried sarwagenknecht
störnfriedin das richtig gechendert ist
weg ist könnte sich die Partei DIE LINKE
ja neu überlegen wie sie jetzt versucht
wieder Land zu gewinnen sie ist im
Existenzkampf da ist keineswegs
gesichert oder das nächste oder
übernächste ja noch politisch überlebt
was worauf muss sie sich jetzt
konzentrieren das ist ja auch ein Thema
das für Sie wichtig ist sie stehen vor
einem wichtigen Wahlkampf und müssen ja
auch klar machen warum die Menschen die
Linke wählen
sollen ja ich glaube erstmal dass jetzt
nach diesen nicht nur Monaten sondern
wirklich jahrelang zehren und und
wirklich Streitigkeiten darum äh gibt es
jetzt einfach Klarheit und klare
Verhältnisse wobei ich auch dazu sagen
muss wenn man sagt man geht dann soll
man auch eben ganz gehen und sie soll
diese Entscheidung dann auch für sich
treffen und auch das Mandat zurückgeben
dass man da wirklich einen klaren
Schluss hat finde ich weil dann gibt es
das uns die Chance wieder ähm auch
wiederum uns zu sortieren und auch zu
sagen okay wir können jetzt mit diesen
clanverhältnissen Leben und wir haben
jetzt auch die Zeit und die Möglichkeit
uns programmatisch und strategisch zu
erneuern denn das was ich auch heute
gehört habe an den Infoständen was die
Leute mir gesagt haben die Linke
streitet zu viel natürlich das ist ein
Problem und das interessiert die Leute
ja auch nicht was wir miteinander uns
besprechen sondern die Leute
interessiert ob sie ihre Miete bezahlen
können oder Ihren Einkauf das ist das
was ich heute dazu gehört habe und das
ist aber auch das wofür wir uns
interessieren wir setzen uns
bedingungslos für die Interessen der
Menschen in diesem Land ein egal woher
sie kommen welche Probleme sie haben und
das muss wieder nach vorne gestellt
werden also wir sind diejenigen die die
vertreten die 12 Millionen
armutsbetroffen in diesem Land
diejenigen die eben nicht wissen wo sie
dann eine neue Wohnung finden sollen die
alleiner Zehen und so weiter und die
werden eben von niemand anderen in
diesem Parteienspektrum vertreten und
deswegen braucht es die linke und das
müssen wir ganz klar wieder nach vorne
stellen es liegt nicht daran dass wir
ein schlechtes Programm gehabt hätten
oder ähm irgendwie das sozusagen nicht
richtig ausbustabiert hätten sondern die
Frage ist wie glaubwürdig ist man dabei
und deswegen fahre ich hier durch den
Osten und höre den Leuten zu weil ich
nämlich glaube dass diese Belange und
diese Frustration die viele Ostdeutsche
insbesondere spüren natürlich eine wahre
Grundlage hat und die spricht Sarah
wagenkncht an aber sie spricht sie eben
falsch sie wird sie auch nicht lösen und
die Linke ist die Partei die das
eigentlich als einzige tun kann und
deswegen bin ich ja auch habe ich mich
dafür entschieden mich DAF einzusetzen
weil ich glaube wenn diese Partei
wegfallen würde dann haben wir nämlich
genau das Problem dann haben wir nur
rechten Kulturkampf von allen Seiten und
dann können wir gar nichts mehr dar dran
machen und wirklich an den
Lebensbedingungen der Menschen ganz ganz
basalen Interessen etwas zu verändern
entschuldigung aber das kann man noch
jetzt wirklich in dieser Pauschalität
nicht sagen dass wir dann nur noch wenn
die Linkspartei ist nicht mehr geben
würde dass wir dann nur noch Kulturkampf
von rechter Seite überall hätten das ist
doch nicht also so können sie doch nicht
auf die anderen Parteien schauen da gibt
es doch schon große Unterschiede also
das würden jetzt sehr viele von sich
weisen das finde ich na ja sie haben
jetzt ja gerade das Spiegelcover gesehen
wo Olaf Scholz gesagt hat wir müssen im
großen Stil abschieben ich glaube das
ist ein eindeutiges Zeichen
an diesen gesamten migrationsdiskurs zu
sagen wir reihen uns da ein auch die
Grünen bauen abschiebezentren an den
Außenlagern ähm der EU s w ich finde das
auch gut ich glaube da kann man sagen da
gibt es eine ganz ganz große Koalition
in dieser Hinsicht und die Linke ist die
einzige die da die da sagt wir lassen
Leute nicht im Mittelmeer ertrinken das
ist doch keine das ist doch ganz normale
eine ganz normale humanistische Position
die mus muss doch eine Stimme in der
Parteienlandschaft geben die das sagt
nein das finde ich entschuldigung ich
muss da kurz wiedersprechen das ist eine
sehr selbstgerechte Position das ist
auch ein Teil des Problems wenn jemand
kritische Worte äußert zu
Migrationspolitik ihn dann gleich in die
AFD Ecke zu stellen es war im übrigen
auch nichts Neues was olulaf Scholz dem
Spiegel gesagt hat er das im Mai schon
angekündigt und es muss sich etwas
ändern in der Migrationspolitik das ist
völlig richtig und das bedeutet nicht
dass man deswegen rechts oder gar
rechtsextrem sei sondern das bedeutet
dass man auf eine große Krise reagieren
muss wir hab jetzt nur noch 90 Sekunden
ganz kurz Gag dass man Kulturkämpfe
führt und dass man nicht über die
wirklichen Probleme spricht frach zwei
kurze politikberaterische Tipps an die
Linke erstens warum nutzt man nicht das
Potenzial da wo man exekutiv erfolgreich
war diese Personen die in den letzten
Jahren auch während Krisen Verantwortung
getragen haben in Regierung auf der
Landesebene sind nicht sichtbar in der
Partei erster Punkt zweiter Punkt
bei der Bundestagswahl 2021 haben
insbesondere diejenigen Menschen für die
Linke gestimmt die sich ein rotgrünrotes
Bündnis erhofft haben daraus würde ich
machen man sollte auf jeden Fall schauen
dass man gestaltungsfähig bleibt als
Linke womöglich mit anderen zusammen und
die nicht vors schnell verpress
Antikapitalismus soll auch Sarah Wagen
Knecht und ihre Überzeugungen prägen
wenn man das jetzt so alles sieht was da
was er jetzt in Bewegung gekommen ist
durch sie hat sie der Linken Sache einen
Bärendienst
erwiesen ich glaube nicht dass sie der
Vorwurf zu machen ist denn Ines spten
hat ja selbst auch gesagt über Wochen
über Monate über Jahre hinweg wurde
immer klarer dass da was nicht mehr
zusammenpasst und sich das jetzt noch
weiter jahrelang anzugucken hätte glaube
ich auch zu bedeutungs zum
Bedeutungsverlust der linken geführt ich
glaube es ist dieser klare Schnitt der
kommt für die Linke jetzt der war
überfällig gut dann sind wir hier
vorerst bei diesem Thema am Ende aber
kommen darauf sicherlich wieder zurück
ich bedanke mich bei Julia ruschenbach
bei Ines Schwertner bei Hanna Betke und
bei Sebastian Puschner Liebe Zuschauerin
liebe Zuschauer morgen in der
phönixrunde Eskalation in Nahost
krisendiplomatie auf hochtur Aktuelles
bei Phönix der Tag mit Thomas Bade Thema
unter anderem die Lage im Nahen Osten
bleib Sie bei
[Musik]
uns